[Music]
once we have our API is enabled head to
the IOT core page to create a device
registry give it a name and choose your
closest region then use MQTT protocol
under defaults lemon tree topic create a
new topic give that a name then click
create to create your new device
registry with an associated pub subtopic
for publishing the telemetry events now
switch to your terminal to generate a
device key pair back to the IOT core
registry details page we will add a
device go to the devices tab then click
create a device enter a device ID and
then choose RS 256 x.509 under the
public key format get the text from the
RSA cert PEM file that you generated
earlier including the begin certificate
and end certificate lines and paste it
into the public key value field click
create to add this device to the
registry now you'll run some code and
connect to this device and view the
telemetry data grab this node code from
github for IOT core navigate to the MQTT
example folder copy the private key from
before to this folder then install the
node dependencies
now you can create a subscription to the
pub subtopic that this registry uses
next connect to the virtual device with
the cloud IOT core over the MQTT bridge
if everything is set up correctly you'll
now see 25 payload messages published
check the pub subtopic now to confirm
it's getting messages published to it
you can run that pub sub subscriptions
pool command again to get more messages
and congratulations you've got your
Internet of Things service running on
Google Cloud
[Music]